[Music]
in 1898 Marie and Pierre Curie
discovered radium claimed to have
restorative properties radium was added
to toothpaste medicine water and food
a glowing luminous green it was also
used in beauty products and jewelry it
wasn't until the mid 20th century we
realized that radium's harmful effects
as a radioactive element outweighed its
visual benefits
unfortunately radium isn't the only
pigment that historically seemed
harmless or useful but turned out to be
deadly that lamentable distinction
includes a trio of colors and pigments
that we've long used to decorate
ourselves and the things we make white
green and orange our story begins with
white as far back as the 4th century BCE
the ancient Greeks treated lead to make
the brilliant white pigment we know
today the problem in humans lead is
directly absorbed into the body and
distributed to the blood soft tissues
and mineralized tissues once in the
nervous system led mimics and disrupts
the normal functions of calcium causing
damages ranging from learning
disabilities to high blood pressure yet
the practice of using this toxic pigment
continued across time and cultures lead
white was the only practical choice for
white oil or tempera paint until the
19th century to make their paint artists
would grind a block of lead into powder
exposing highly toxic dust particles the
pigments liberal use resulted in what
was known as painters colic or what we'd
now call lead poisoning artists who
worked with lead complained of palsies
melancholy coughing enlarged retinas and
even blindness but lead whites density
opacity and warm tone were irresistible
to artists like Vermeer and later the
Impressionists its glow couldn't be
matched and the pigment continued to be
widely used until it was banned in the
1970s as bad as all that sounds whites
dangerous effects pale in comparison to
another more widespread Pigman
Green to synthetic greens called Sheils
green and Paris green were first
introduced in the 18th century they were
far more vibrant and flashy than the
relatively dull greens made from natural
pigments so they quickly became popular
choices for paint as well as dye for
textiles wallpaper soaps cake
decorations toys candy and clothing
these green pigments were made from a
compound called Kubrick hydrogen arsenic
in humans exposure to arsenic can damage
the way cells communicate and function
and high levels of arsenic have been
directly linked to cancer and heart
disease as a result 18th century fabric
factory workers were often poisoned and
women in green dresses reportedly
collapsed from exposure to arsenic on
their skin bedbugs were rumored not to
live in green rooms and it's even been
speculated that Napoleon died from slow
arsenic poisoning from sleeping in his
green wallpapered bedroom the intense
toxicity of these greens stayed under
wraps until the arsenic recipe was
published in 1822 and a century later it
was repurposed as an insecticide
synthetic Green was probably the most
dangerous color in widespread use but at
least it didn't share radium's property
of radioactivity another color did
though orange before World War two it
was common for manufacturers of ceramic
dinnerware to use uranium oxide in
colored glazes the compound produced
brilliant reds and oranges which were
appealing attributes if not for the
radiation they emitted of course
radiation was something we were unaware
of into the late 1800s let alone the
associated cancer risks which we
discovered much later during World War
two
the US government confiscated all
uranium for use in bomb development
however the Atomic Energy Commission
relaxed these restrictions in 1959 and
depleted uranium returned to ceramics
and glass factory floors orange dishes
made during the next decade may still
have some hazardous qualities on their
surfaces to this day most notably
vintage Fiestaware reads positive
for radioactivity and while the levels
are low enough that they don't
officially pose a health risk if they're
on a shelf the US EPA warns against
eating food off of them though we still
occasionally run into issues with
synthetic food dyes our scientific
understanding has helped us prune
hazardous colors out of our lives
[Music]
Oh